speaking of being rebellious when you
hear someone like like Joe Biden it
doesn't have to be Joe Biden either this
could be anyone who made a statement
when he told Charlemagne if you're
having trouble choosing between me and
Donald Trump then you ain't black
right now I imagine that are that act
that's actual statement comes up in in
various ways in even in the black
community you said you move from West
Side of Chicago to the suburbs and that
can even be if you go back to the west
side then all of a sudden well now you
don't live here so you ain't black or
you can you can you you there are
different contexts for a statement like
the statements the wrong word even it
seems so it would make a distinction for
win black people use that first I don't
think that's something that black people
do to each other a lot there you know
hold it like you ain't black right I
definitely saw growing up me know it's
definitely a reality it's definitely
reality but but here's what I think
black people in general tend to mean by
that
usually when black people say something
like you ain't black there's usually a
sense of you must think you ain't black
you must think that because you live
with the white people over there well
because you come from money or because
you don't live on the streets
you must have forgot that you black you
must think that because you left the
neighborhood just because you left the
neighborhood right um and sometimes
that's directed at a real thing so uh P
deenis is also a thing in black
communities right it is possible to be a
black person and think you better than
other black people because maybe you
grew up and you grew up in the suburbs
or maybe you day somebody outside your
race or maybe you have more money
whatever and now you think you're better
and if you go around black people
talking to black people as if you are
you know you know some higher level of
blackness black people will quickly
remind you of your blackness and usually
that kind of statement is kind of like
it's getting at that it's a very nuanced
thing what joe said was not nuanced at
all I just think it was completely
stupid silly ignorant and uninformed but
I think it was telling I think the
reason he felt comfortable saying
something that is so obviously stupid
and obviously false and by the way like
it's very important to me that I don't
find it a more charitable term than
stupid it's very important to me that
even though I'm capable of using about
ten words instead of that that I choose
to use that one because it's absolutely
stupid if you say if you don't vote for
me
you ain't black the best word to
describe what you said is stupid right
and and and and it's insulting and it's
offensive and it should be offensive to
everybody but but the reason I think he
was comfortable saying that is because
it's it's it's an indicator of taking
black people for granted it's a way of
saying we got y'all it's a way of saying
I can be overconfident because I know
that you guys always vote Democrat I can
predict how you guys are gonna vote and
I know that you guys have already bought
into the narrative that Trump is racist
right so as long as I'm not Trump I can
do whatever I want to do I can say
whatever I want to say and I don't have
to worry about you and any of your
concerns and being intelligent enough to
speak to your concerns intelligently I
can just say hey you know I'm not Trump
so I already got you that's the kind of
that's the way you talk to people when
you're not afraid to lose people and I
think it was a great wake up call
it's like saying take it or leave it you
know what in a weird way and you know
I'm
it seems incredibly cavalier I agree
that it's stupid but it's almost like
beyond stupid in a way where where you
you have to realize that if you think
this election is as consequential as
you're claiming and that it is that you
you would want to you would want the
support of a group that you feel has
been disenfranchised by this
administration and if that's what you're
claiming then I don't know man it's it's
weird that we took what we take for
granted and by the way I think we all do
this to a great extent unless we make a
concerted effort you know the Stoics
often talk about naked
visualization yeah and and that's one
thing I often you know after we talked
to William Irvine on on the podcast he's
a a stoic philosopher at Wright State
and the one thing he taught me out of
that is the the negative visualization
exercise with backs I'll often just say
hey thanks for existing because like the
opposite of her existing is her being
dead and me thinking about her being
dead right now makes me be really it
makes me really grateful that she exists
and the opposite of what Joe Biden could
have done they're saying hey I want to
thank the black community for existing
and I want to show you that you know my
agenda happens to be the better agenda I
actually have it you know a black agenda
as opposed to his black agenda seems to
be that he happened he was a vice
president for the first black president
right like that's not an agenda yeah and
you know Freight for anybody who thinks
well maybe that's a little harsh to call
it stupid I think we can make a
distinction between stupid people and
stupid statements right we don't have to
believe that people are stupid I believe
that people including Joe Biden are
capable of learning from their mistakes
I think he may have done a lot of damage
that may be very difficult for him to
come back from as far as the election is
concerned we'll see but I think I think
anybody can learn from that for sure but
I think a part of learning is being real
about what we need to learn and if we
treat stupid things as if they are at
the same level of sophisticated things
how will we ever value the importance of
doing it this sophisticated way right
like we can't motivate people to learn
to do things the right way if we pretend
like there's no difference between right
and wrong it was a stupid thing to say